When I first started,
I got a phone call from a woman
whose daughter was an equestrian
and the woman was very upset
because her daughter's
coach had been removed,
had been banned by the
Center for SafeSport
for sexual misconduct.
I was assuming that she was calling to
kind of talk through
what that really meant.
Instead, she called me
to ask me to remove him
from our disciplinary database,
even though he had been removed with cause
because it was her daughter's coach,
and that was the only coach that
her daughter would work with.
And I just found it, just mind blowing
that here you have a mother,
who I'm sure loves her daughter very much
and wants nothing but
the best for her child.
But at the same time was
willing to put her child at risk
with someone who shouldn't
have been around kids.
Who had done some pretty terrible things
because she wanted her child to win.
What I didn't realize
when I first began reporting this story,
is how deep the divisions
run with an equestrian.
This is a community that has
been torn apart by SafeSport.
SafeSport is an agency
that was established by Congress in 2017,
to effectively be the watchdog
over all Olympic sporting communities,
when it comes to sexual misconduct.
The center has been criticized
by a number of Olympic sports
for not doing enough to support survivors.
But what surprised me
about the equestrian
community in particular,
is that here we are seeing members
actually push back against SafeSport
in defense of the accused.
I was kind of like
SafeSport is this third party organization
but they need to like mind
their own business in a way
and stay out of the USEF.
Not only are they challenging
the center's process,
but they are demanding
for the reinstatement
of some athletes who have been
brought down by the center.
This was the first time that these people
were are being held accountable
and accountability makes
people uncomfortable.
Equestrian, like many sports,
is having to kind of have a reckoning
within their community.
And some are not happy about it.
These families are wealthy.
We're talking about the
daughters of billionaires,
of rock stars, of royalty.
This is a community that is not afraid
to stand up for what it believes in,
to challenge or to question authorities.
And it's definitely
not afraid to push back
when it thinks they're getting it wrong.
People can mobilize to make change.
That's how the Center for
SafeSports started, right?
People were angry, they wanted change
and they saw change happen.
So I've got no issue with that
but you gotta ask yourself,
why are you vocal against an organization
that is holding people accountable?
When I was nine years old,
eight or nine years old,
I went to Sacramento International
and it was a World Cup
qualifiers was a big 160 class.
And I remember just watching that class
thinking that's gonna be me one day.
I had no doubt in my mind
that that's what I was gonna be doing.
Two years later, same show,
I was sitting in those same stands.
I was watching the World's
Cup qualifier and Rich won it.
And I remember being so
amazed by Rich and Flexible,
and I thought, okay, that's
who I need to ride with
to get to the top of the sport.
Rich Fellers is an Olympic team veteran.
He won the 2012 World Cup
Final in the Netherlands.
He was probably one of the most respected
and well known trainers in the country.
Rich Fellers and Flexible, 26.61 to beat
and he did it, what a tremendous.
I talked to many young women
who at the age of 14 or
15 moved across cities
in order to be able to ride
at an elite level with a top trainer,
some who even moved to different countries
because they knew that was the trainer
that was gonna get them on the path
of where they wanted to go,
where they felt like they needed to go.
When I was 14, is when I
decided to move to the Fellers.
They were in Oregon and
I was in California.
And so it was kind of
agreed upon by everyone
that I would go and stay with them.
Maggie from the day she was born
was always very independent.
She would never even hold
my hand when she was two.
She just was so intense and
so focused and so driven.
So when she decided she
wanted to go up to Oregon
and ride with the Fellers we said,
'Okay, we can make that happen.'
Maggie's routine was so
straightforward and so strong.
She would get up at 7:00 AM.
She would get ready.
She would drive to the barn.
If she wasn't riding at the barn
she was working at the barn.
And then she would go home,
take a shower, do some
schoolwork, go to sleep
and get up the next
day and go to the barn.
Your relationship with your trainer
is probably strongest
relationship in your life.
They build you up and they
teach you everything you know
and you grow as a person when
you're training with them.
The more time you spend with
them, the more you trust them.
And they are the strongest
voice in your life.
I think that that
relationship is important.
But I think in my case,
the line is crossed.
And I think in a lot of
cases, the line gets crossed
Maggie Kehring under the
watchful eye of Rich Fellers.
We had just had a Christmas party.
It was like a big barn Christmas party.
The Fellers' invited all their friends
and nothing happened there.
It was two days after I got this call
and he was like,
'something's just been
building up inside me
the past six months.
I'm crazy about you.
I have these really
strong feelings about you.
You can't tell anyone,
this is very personal'
but he's like, 'it's okay, don't worry.
I'll get it under control
and everything will be fine.
I'll go back to normal.'
And I remember just sitting in shock.
How old were you?
I was 16.
The moment the announcement was made
that I was gonna be the CEO,
I remember later that day
getting a direct message
on Facebook of all places
from this woman who
happened to be an equestrian
basically warning me of
what I was stepping into
and that I really needed
to take a close look
at the entire community at
the Center for SafeSport,
because it was going to be tough for me.
Mom,
don't you wanna know why coach
keeps texting me so much.
The U.S. Center for SafeSport
is a nonprofit 501c3 organization
that opened its doors back in 2017
which is right in the middle of the midst
of the Larry Nassar scandal
with USA gymnastics.
This morning, dozens of
Larry Nassar's victims
will have their voices heard in court.
There is now nowhere left
for you to hide Larry.
More than 160 women say Larry
Nassar sexually abused them.
Before the Center for SafeSport opened
there really wasn't an
organization in this country,
in this world, that focused
on the issues that we do.
Within the Olympic and
Paralympic Movement,
national governing bodies
were really responsible
for investigating any sort of allegation
that may have come their way,
which some may handled
well, some they didn't.
And what we saw was that
there was just a conflict
of interest to have
an organization start to
investigate allegations of abuse
within their own ranks.
The center did a study last
year where we looked at
data coming from 4,000 athletes
across the Olympic Movement.
And we got representation from every sport
within the Olympic and
Paralympic, which was significant.
And what we found was that
93% of athletes who had experienced abuse
had not reported it.
That is a significant
number and very troubling.
As a movement and as a
community and as an organization
we have to do more to really help people
understand what abuse looks like
but also to help them
become more comfortable
in reporting it.
That is the only way
that we're going to start
shifting the narrative.
It's hard to understand until
you're put in that situation
but he was the person who
was fully developing me
into who I was becoming.
And that is kind of the
power imbalance of it all.
And so I just blindly trusted him.
And I do have to say in
the beginning, I did say no
I was very firm and I
tried to be supportive
because I did care about him.
I did have strong relationship with him,
but I did say no several times.
And I was like, that's not
the way I feel about you.
And then he kind of kept pushing
and I kind of just accepted that.
And then that slowly progressed into like
me being at the barn with him.
And he'd pull me aside
on a horse and be like
I just had to tell you
that I'm in love with you.
And he was like, I never understood
how I could feel love like this until now.
And he'd say stuff like
this is too good to lose.
That's probably when I'd say
that I started to actually love him.
I think it lasted around six months.
It was just after her 17th birthday
that their relationship turned sexual.
And in the State of Oregon,
the age of consent is 18.
Maggie and Rich's relationship
actually ended quite publicly
at a horse show in Michigan.
She had traveled there with
him and his wife and his son
and they were all sharing an
Airbnb near the show grounds.
And one night his wife,
Shelley Fellers walked
in on them together.
A lot of the blame was put on me,
even though I didn't really know
what I'd really gotten myself into.
I was kind of just following
the leader who was Rich.
I called my mom, she came to Michigan.
She brought me to a hotel
and I remember just looking
out the hotel window
looking at the concrete below me thinking
I understand why people
kill themselves now.
Like it was felt like
the only release of pain.
And I was in so much pain.
And I felt like I had
just lost everything.
I had lost the person who I had loved,
the family who I loved.
I had lost my trainers,
my whole support system.
Just everything crashed down real quick.
It was so bad.
I think for months and
months, I just operated
as I just have to keep Maggie alive
and I have to keep my
younger daughter functioning.
That's all I could do.
And I couldn't look up from any of it.
In the aftermath of all this
Maggie wasn't allowed
to return to the stable.
So her and her four
horses never came back.
That raised a lot of questions.
And on top of that, she's a teenager.
She uses social media
and she was posting
videos of herself crying,
photographs of her with Rich,
song lyrics talking about
how she was in love with him.
More than a dozen people
reported the relationship
between Rich Fellers and Maggie Kehring
to the United States Center for SafeSport
but SafeSport couldn't take any action
without Maggie's consent.
So she decided six months after
the relationship had ended
when she'd gone through
depression, suicidality,
trying to get back on a horse
again, trying to ride again
trying to find herself again
that she was going to report him
to the United States Center for SafeSport.
And when she did the
center acted immediately.
Police arrested Richard Fellers
a prominent competitor
and trainer in the equestrian industry.
And it was the organization,
the U.S. Center for SafeSport
that provided the information to police.
This here is the 61
year old's booking photo
taken on Monday after
police arrested Fellers
on four counts of second
degree sexual abuse
Rich Fellers was issued a
lifetime ban from SafeSport.
He didn't pursue arbitration
but he has pleaded not guilty
to the charges in court.
A trial date is expected
to be set in April
and he declined to comment for the story.
A lot of people stood by Rich
when the initial allegations came out.
A lot of people attacked Maggie
and what we've seen in the aftermath
is this growing sense of people realizing
that actually this is
a problem in the sport.
The grooming of young
riders by their coaches
in powerful positions has happened
and is still happening today.
Up to the end of 2021 SafeSport
had issued 47 sanctions
against the equestrian community.
And this is quite a lot when
you compare it to tennis
an organization that has
eight times as many members
but has had only 35 sanctions
up until that point.
You say the SafeSport needs a lot of work.
Is this not enough? Is it
not a strong enough system
to protect younger gymnasts
in place right now?
SafeSport's been around
for about five years
and the center has seen its
fair share of criticism.
We have seen gymnasts like Aly Raisman
testifying before Congress saying that
SafeSport doesn't do enough
to support survivors.
They try to avoid doing it.
Like they'll say you need to
pass it on to this person.
And then the person that we
actually report to will say,
well, actually go back to SafeSport.
It's like they play hot potato
with who should take the report.
We've seen sports calling out SafeSport
for taking too long in
its investigative process
for asking too much of survivors
demanding that they
deliver too much evidence
to prove an allegation.
We pride ourselves on being very thorough.
Some investigations
might take a few weeks.
Some may take a few months.
Others have been known to take years
just because of the complexity
of the investigation.
This is not something that we take lightly
because this has so much
impact on people's lives.
It is not something that
we are willing to kind of cut corners on.
Equestrian is the on only sport
that is mobilizing against SafeSport
in defense of the accused.
We have seen members of this community
create anti SafeSport petitions
that have garnered
thousands of signatures.
We've seen it create
nonprofit organizations
which have raised over $2.5 million
to lobby Congress and challenge
SafeSport's authority,
to try and limit the powers
that the watchdog has.
Within the equestrian community
the main criticisms against SafeSport
are that it lacks due process,
that it lacks transparency
and that it is effectively
labeling coaches guilty
until proven innocent.
The question about the
extent of the division
within the sport is a good one.
My sense from my conversations
with colleague, peers
is that it runs pretty deep.
In 1989 Ray Texel won
the two most prestigious
medal finals in the U.S.
He's a well-known trainer.
He's at the top level of his sport.
And he also feels
as though SafeSport has been
operating like a secret court.
The feeling of it is, you
don't know what's going on
this is not falling in the
criminal justice system
or the justice system.
It's a step towards it.
And I think that's where a
lot of the division comes from
is not wanting to support
something of that nature.
That's operating in that way.
But at the same time
supporting its message and its purpose.
And there's a conflict there.
People in my community are
afraid of, related to SafeSport,
is very specifically the use
of SafeSport as a weapon,
whether that's for retribution,
whether that's displeasure with somebody,
of course that's a very scary proposition.
So my early thoughts of
SafeSport were definitely
influenced by people around me.
And a lot of people were trainers.
I heard things like
SafeSport is witch hunt.
These are innocent trainers,
not doing anything.
And if clients don't like them
they can go after them
for absolutely anything.
I never really understood
what SafeSport was
until I actually needed
to go through with it.
And it's a lot different
from what people think
I kind of was like
I'm just gonna make a social media post.
It's going be over,
going to keep moving on.
And then so many women
started reaching out to me,
so many women and men,
of all ages talking about their stories.
And I was like, okay, wait,
I am not the only one.
This is a huge problem in our industry
that is not talked about enough.
All that's talked about is
how SafeSport is witch hunt
and how SafeSport is awful and
how we need to get rid of it
and how could this be put in place?
And I think a lot of times
some people forget that I'm
still like an 18 year old girl.
Who's coming out the situation.
That's not like it's 10 years behind me.
It's still fairly close.
One of the things
that the equestrian
community has struggled with
is that it's seen some of the
most prestigious trainers,
athletes and Olympic champions
brought down by SafeSport.
One thing I've definitely come to realize
over the course of this reporting is that
this is a sport that doesn't
like to watch its heroes fall.
For me SafeSport became
the most polarizing
when the person, I think in our community,
that we all looked to the most,
the one with the biggest
voice George Morris,
my former mentor and trainer.
When he was set down, I
think that was really maybe
one of the more significant moments
when it really hit hard for many people
that this was real and serious.
When George Morris was removed from sport.
I don't think that anyone
inside of SafeSport
could have predicted the just emotional
like outcry of that decision.
It was something that we
had never seen before.
The 'I Stand with George'
hashtag was, was circulating.
And people were just really
just angry with the center
because this was someone
who had been in this
community for decades.
He was still coaching.
He was a pillar within this community.
This guy had his own action figures.
Like this was someone that
they really looked up to.
And so for him to be called out like this
for him to be removed,
people were just angry.
Within 48 hours of the George Morris ban
a group called 'I Stand With George'
had popped up on Facebook
and it had more than 4,200 members.
They sent angry emails to SafeSport.
They called the center.
They did everything they could
to demand his reinstatement.
They didn't believe that George Morris
should be brought down by allegations
dating back to the 1970s.
They want to know why and how
SafeSport can operate outside
and beyond the scope of the
criminal justice system.
Not having a statute
of limitations in place
allowed people to one, take their time
to come to the Center for
SafeSport when they felt ready
but also know that
we were not going to put
some arbitrary timeline
on when you could do that.
And while this was novel,
I think back in 2017 when we
opened up the organization.
States across this country
are starting to reverse
these statute limitations
on child sexual abuse.
And so it is going to become the norm.
George Morris was accused
of sexual misconduct
against two minors
dating back to the 1970s.
In the wake of his lifetime ban
he sought arbitration and lost.
He's also fighting a civil case
in the courts against his accuser.
George Morris's lawyer has told us
that he denies any improper conduct.
You'll see is the higher
that people kind of rise up in their sport
or the better they get or
the more well known they get.
I think there's just more at stake
and when there's more at stake
people's behavior starts to change.
And so for us really taking to account
the competitiveness of the sport
but also reminding people constantly
that it's not all about
winning at the end of the day
we've gotta make sure
that athletes are safe.
And that may mean that
we don't win sometimes.
And that's okay.
Our community for sure stands behind
the rights for victims.
We want the best for our young
and we want the best for our old.
So it's not an attack on SafeSport.
It's not an attack on
anybody, but it's a dialogue.
Is this the best application?
Your are so beautiful.
I think that as a reporter,
I'm really grateful
to those who were willing
to open up their lives to us
to sit down and talk
to us to explain about
what had happened to them,
not just the abuse but what led up to it.
One of the things that
Maggie Kehring has done
for this sport is she's
allowed other young people
to step out of the shadows
to break their own silence.
He took away my sense of self, who I was,
my character was very
much built around him
and everything he had taught me.
So he shattered who I was as a person.
Like after that, I felt lost.
I didn't know who I was anymore.
And even now I'm still
trying to find myself again
who I am as an individual,
not in that family,
with those people around
me, influencing who I am.